where we're all being moved out of the
airport now towards the emergency exit
there is a great deal of confusion here
and certainly there are a number of as
you might imagine very upset very
frightened people again we don't know
about the number number of injuries but
certainly the people I am with here
certainly believe that there is a
terrorist attack although again we can't
we can't confirm that hasn't been
confirmed by the authorities but we've
been moved now as you can see probably
in our live picture we've been moved
towards an emergency exit I think of
course there are there are fears but
there may be other attackers that is
clearly what we have seen in the past
with terror attacks on European soil
multiple spectacular attacks by
terrorists targeting key buildings key
institutions